[Music]
in how to get fired news somebody by rad
Chad a local TV reporter was fired for
jumping on classic cars during a live
segment I saw this this [ __ ] is
a piece of [ __ ] he really is
wait what I thought he was being
hilarious he's like trying to impress
the female anchors is he like jumping
out what of ones I had expect this from
a youtuber yeah a [ __ ] newscast this
is a newscaster who's a wannabe tuber if
I ever saw one of my life I don't know
okay know that I know who you're talking
about that's okay okay so this guy's
name is angel Cardenas he's not one of
you guys are an [ __ ]
thank you you bet that guy's an [ __ ]
he's jumping on [ __ ] Thunderbirds and
[ __ ] no spoilers no spoilers
he's guarding his channel so he's on
good days at Sacramento he was doing a
live segment on this Auto Show oh god
woman is it the Meachem auto auctions
Sacramento International Auto Show no
yeah
becomes pretty big you know about 100
Jackson's nope no P or no D is that
something else
what is SEMA yeah so that's when it was
recorded by people and posted on
Facebook and it was shared the summer
kick his ass oh oh yeah wait you're
gonna show you a show it this is the
glitter this is the clip from the live
segment and why does it look like it's
in the 80s it's just a really bad
quality cuz it was alive it was a light
so it was recording over a TV Oh
- for explore things to be fun brand new
Ford this is not the end of the segment
that's a Ford Explorer he's living on
the wild side kid in a candy store
without the owner nobody is looking are
you kidding me oh he's so bad if those
cars are original paint he's [ __ ] up
like hundred thousand dollar cars that's
what people are commenting that cuz like
there was one t-bird owner who said like
is he like my paint is so delicate like
that literally cost hundreds of
thousands of going into a museum and
he's all like the world's last jar oops
nobody's here we'll [ __ ] the world's
last jar oh yeah it's pretty bad so
luckily though he got fired
yay what about the girl yeah the girl
get off my [ __ ] wavelength yeah haha
no the good the newscaster whoops they
were actually asking him to get off the
car yeah they were in the studio they're
like you should get down oh and then
right before this board part where he
jumps on he actually talks too so there
were two people there from the Auto Show
they were they tell him what they're
farther there
anyway so then but then one lady who he
did interview for the segment he ends up
telling her like who's do I see there's
signs up please stay off the display or
whatever he's like hey so do you think I
could jump on the hood or she said
something like I'm not gonna look her
she was just trying to play along I'm
pretty sure she did not think he was
gonna do what he did like at least to
the point where like he did it cuz even
put his shoes on top and that's when
they finally asked him like you need to
get down it sounds like a [ __ ] hit
newscaster joke ray at first to her so
she's like oh I'm not gonna look they're
trying to be cute oh yeah yeah not like
yes you can do this yeah there's a
[ __ ] talking only Ford's
american-made he doesn't like those
Chevy or he's one of their people that
wore Thunderbirds and Ford Explorer
Mexican not an ass no so then uh well
Ford builds in Mexico so he can chill
that [ __ ] looked so bad enough he looked
like a wreck too he looked like you've
been drinking all night and you didn't
[ __ ] like this all I'm talking yeah
what the [ __ ]
and look it feels like you would see
this like on a Will Ferrell movie you
know like it didn't show yeah I can't do
it and you're just like oh yeah my
brother so he actually it talks about
that
so anyway range fast man Sacramento
International Auto Show they posted on
their Facebook this and it says after
the producer of the Sacramento
International Auto Show reached out to
the general manager of K max TV
regarding yesterday's astonishingly
awful incident she received a call this
morning from the GM that the reporter
from the good day Sacramento segment has
been terminated immediately in the
station express their sincere apologies
for the incident oh then there's this
email here from this dude angel what's
the name angel happiness yes so he says
Hank thank you for watching good day and
thank you for the feedback I hear your
concern I do apologize if you were
offended by my actions during the live
shot I can assure you those vehicles
were not damaged at all and they do
report that they weren't damaged I knew
from the type of leap I was doing that
save maneuver on this vehicle yeah car
owners like he just got lucky everyone
saying like how the anyway so then this
he says the door hitting was a staged
move I may have crossed I may have
crossed the line a bit but my intentions
were never to disrespect the owners of
the vehicles although it seemed that way
I was really it was really a dumb choice
on my part I'll be personally reaching
out to them to offer my sincere apology
again thank you for your feedback but
then also in the segment like he'll grab
like the display sign for these owners
like for the keywords and their people
that were watching and they were doing
their own commentary because they
required and posted on Facebook they're
like how [ __ ] disrespectful do like
grab mercy I told you you can touch both
cars I want to add something in can you
go back to that email real quick the
very bottom of it it says film guy dude
bleep oh god nice I like this guy now
that makes me like him actually yeah
jumping on cars like the 100 leap or
what like very gracious what classy guy
man I know I'm gonna say yeah big fan
world people asked well whatever okay
I'm filling in the blanks here but then
like old-school media right have you
seen like recently how they're trying to
be more realistic and relatable yeah
like what if there's this whole push of
like oh you know we gotta stop seeming
so stiff why don't you go optionality on
yeah did you see what the youtubers
doing we should do what they're doing
right cuz there's been some charity so
like that and it makes me feel weird
like stop it
yeah and he just took that message and
he goes well I'll be myself asshat
so apparently according to nice I see
two buttons yeah
oh yeah according to LinkedIn page he
has been contributing to good day
Sacramento since at least 2012 so now
he's annoyed well he [ __ ] up yeah he
just destroyed a career and I usually in
day I usually hate when people get fired
for [ __ ] but this one I'm like good yeah
he deserves it how do you apply to be a
reporter though journalism yeah you go
through a local channel to that
Sacramento who knows yeah it could be I
have no [ __ ] idea well you could
major and gern reporting and journey dia
and all that stuff munication yeah you
don't even have to be good on camera
obviously look at [ __ ] everybody on a
news the rough yeah they are well it's
so so stiff and [ __ ] boring
that's right Stephen they really are you
know it Jia you always know how to
[ __ ] crack me up Jim let the
inclement weather they like the best
[ __ ] and then you see just people in the
background walk I'm like I love those
guys you know what about this morning do
the worst ever pretty bad but enhancing
them since I was in high school but I
remember in high school I still turn on
the TV and I used to always like
watching KTLA cuz they see him like
there were really fun especially this
one chick like choose a younger one she
was all like real like she never had
that anchor voice I mean she might have
been just like real normal too and just
like the comparison of everyone else
being so bad true but she was also
always talking about she's on medication
I she'll get depressed and [ __ ]
Julianne I was listening to this podcast
about how the world shifted in the last
like 20 years right cuz like if we were
kids
if there was the news person or whatever
they're a [ __ ] celebrity like if you
see them at the grocery store you're
like oh my god
right yeah but in there talking about
how PewDiePie records from his bedroom
and he's like what's up guys
that's a real celebrity oh yeah cuz like
if one of our news anchors goes out
that's a local celebrity right but no
one gives a [ __ ] anymore if you see one
you're like oh yeah they're on the news
you don't go Wow
I mean like influencers are like even
even you know like Ryan like if he goes
he's a mega [ __ ] star compared to
like whoa like celebrities on TV I
didn't announce where he was like four
hours before I do right there do you
think that's a California or an alley
specific hmm I think it's even bigger
when you go out of state cuz like
California specifically LA I feel like I
see so many celebrities and influencers
to the point and in my world I'm just
like they're always out here thirds
you're right and by the way Mitt Romney
has to tweet himself like I said earlier
you're saying yeah yeah like how sad is
that
like the guys aren't even that Rell
imagine living in Oklahoma or something
and then you go oh [ __ ] its Logan Paul
versus apart yeah versus if they saw
like I understand coop like like a star
like yeah like Anderson Cooper I don't
know yeah
the youth right now Scarlett Johansson
vs. PewDiePie which one do you think
they'll go for I think PewDiePie a
thousand percent they feel like they
know depends on how old they are
it's a powerful difference man cuz I
remember watching Mark Wahlberg start a
YouTube channel like if I'm home a bunch
of years ago he like was doing a couple
videos and there's no engagement there
because nobody feels like they know Mark
Wahlberg they know movie star Mark
Wahlberg that's it but when you feel
like you know someone it's a powerful
thing powerful connection
[Music]